Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
This is going to be my Gotham Episode 7 video.
Some of the best Riddler scenes I think we've
gotten all season long.
So just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet.
Towards the end of season one that they were
teasing like a really strong Riddler are in
now were really starting to see the fruits
of that report were slowly getting towards
full-blown Riddler costume but the actor the
place where there was talking about the next
version of his costume it's going to be green
but were not can you see any question marks
on it but we will see him dropping more riddles
in Ivy I don't know if we've seen the last
of the shadow self at the shadow Riddler was
is going do top five WTF this there's a whole
bunch of storylines that we need to talk about
starting with number five Catwoman versus
silver St. Cloud this is your standard mean
girl storyline I think were all just looking
forward to Catwoman clawing sobers eyes out
his first story arc's goal like I always enjoy
seeing Catwoman Broussard's but I feel like
this is going to be one of the less interesting
once on the show like like the Riddler Gordon
versus the oh this is going to be a little
bit more thrilling Catwoman versus silver
St. Cloud is what is more like a schoolyard
fight situation unless Catwoman breaks out
her shotgun and shoot silver in the chest
they'll be pretty crazy if Riddler can walk
around with the severed hand then surely Catwoman
can start using that shotgun and some people
but the big problem right now I think is with
Bruce's character he is now one of the dumbest
characters on the show like Gordon finally
figured out what was going on with feel like
you finally like woke up the light bulb turned
on is said that has not happened for Bruce
yet or he's choosing to ignore the warning
signs just because he's so desperate for companions
silver said I'm going to be Bruce's only friend
you don't like trying try to get Catwoman
to go away and imply that if Catwoman didn't
stop hanging out with Bruce she was going
to have her killed a part of me feels like
Bruce actually believes that like his self-esteem
is so low that like if you told them you don't
have any friends part of him would believe
it when he actually does have quite a bit
of friends accordance his friend Alfred's
his friend Catwoman's his friend eventually
you'll realize that but I think is going to
be Catwoman that's gonna take care of silver
just because their conflict is a little bit
more physical I don't see Bruce do a lot of
punching and kicking until as rel comes on
the show and I really don't even know if the
gonna do that character it's the order of
St. Dumas that's the big group of people is
coming to town as rel is just part of that
and actually just to clarify as I saw some
people on my last Gotham video asking whether
or not this is a quarter Val storyline or
this is and as rel storyline actually it's
neither it will eventually turn into a quarter
Val storyline but the court are those original
ruling families of Gotham been kicked the
Dumas out the Dumas family the became the
Galivants is represented by the order of St.
Dumas this is she a large organization that
the Dumas family just kind of integrated into
and co-opted for the first half of this family
is more about the revenge of the Dumas family
and then I think the quarter Val's will rear
its head in response is like if you have a
club you kick someone out than that person
comes back with another organization to try
and take over the original club will eventually
answer in kind with force now obviously we
just we haven't seen the rest of those families
yet voicing the way and we will assume the
Dumas there are other families that will eventually
meet so on the number for Theo versus Bruce
as he explained feels good to try and take
Wayne Enterprises from Bruce take control
it's a little bit like what Boehm did to Batman
during the dark Knight rises to you to take
that big cushion away although in the dark
Knight rises Batman had already spent most
of his wealth so he kind of already pulled
the rug out from under himself that you get
the idea feels slowly trying to take Bruce's
agency as well his his sense of self away
from him so he's waging a physical a psychological
and an economic war against the Wayne family
speaking of physical war onto number three
Penguin versus the oh and now Butch the bridge
part is a little bit more fun but but the
whole reason for them killing penguins mother
I think is twofold one to galvanize Penguin
against the 02 just to show who the real villain
on the show is so that Penguin even though
he's super evil becomes an antihero it is
certain point in two I just I don't think
they knew what to do with the character going
forward they didn't have a compelling arc
for her of all the characters in and around
Penguin in the comics his mother is in a really
big figure so this is not that many direction
to take his mother on the show so she has
to go this is the most efficient way for the
writers to get rid of her like will throw
her under the bus but in doing so will push
Penguin over the edge so Penguin is as declared
war on Theo and everyone around him which
is now Butch although technically Butch is
his own man as he says I'd I think he's being
honest when he says that Penguin was controlling
him like a marionette so now Butch doesn't
have to act like a puppet so much but there
are points last year when he literally acted
like a puppet he danced like a puppet I'm
kinda glad that that's over even though Theo
versus Gotham is all about his war against
the Wayne family I do think that Penguin is
going to be the want to ultimately take Theo
down to like deliver the killing blow speed
which on the number two Gordon versus the
oh Gordon officially declares war on Theo
to his face at the lightbulb finally comes
on is headed in this episode I was wondering
how long it would take them early in the episode
tigress was complaining about how she wasn't
getting to have any fun when you let me have
some fun Theo well this is just the signal
that fund will be had they will be open war
in the street like were moving towards the
midseason finale big battles in order for
that to happen you have to have this this
open villain moment where it feels like you
come in after me book good like you could
try the you're not can succeed so now the
line in the sand has been drawn you have like
Gordon coming up Theo from one direction you
have pain one coming from another direction
yet Theo coming up Bruce from two different
directions everybody's getting ready to start
slinging bullets in the order of St. Dumas
has even got here yet but finally on my favorite
storyline this week the Riddler versus himself
if you ever watched Joss Wiens Buffy Earth
Angel Angel had this bike the internal war
going on himself where there was the and jealous
of the evil version of himself the didn't
have a soul and then there was the angel characters
like a good character that did have a soul
so the Riddler here has his own version of
that only the end jealous version of himself
wins so he cracks a smile and just search
dicing Ms. Kringle's body up I was surprised
that she was dead I think I had to check the
wiki after last week and it was like Ms. Kringle
gravely injured saws like maybe she's not
dead but then sure enough the minute that
severed hand showed up in this episode in
the vending machine no less out like you definitely
did definitely definitely dead that was one
of the best parts do you know better than
the smile the end was him finding the hand
in the vending machine.
The rest of her was hidden behind other vending
machine slots like you have to start hitting
like all the buttons just to get it out Morgan
Anita ship loaded dollar bills to get her
out of there that be like the cartoon version
of Gotham let me know in the comments though
what was your favorite part about the episode
and who do you think is going to be the one
to kill Theo ultimately or do you think that
he's just going to get away anything is gonna
be like fish movie that we won't see like
a severed head or a body James frame is such
a good actor I be really sad at the show lost
them forever so hopefully like double find
some way to explain him getting away like
you do want to see the Penguin twist the blade
inside and just just to get a little bit of
revenge but you don't want to see the show
lose the character forever what can happen
next is is Constantine is coming on arrow
is going to be bad ass it's also a big black
canary episode two so be sure to watch it
on TV when it airs even if you've already
watch the episode everybody like winking at
each other so post that video later tonight
after the episode airs but agents of shield
also just revealed the identity of lash, I'll
post that video Thursday in that working on
a Supergirl video that will post later on
Thursday hopefully I'll have a room tour video
sometime soon to I'm having a bunch of furniture
delivered so is you issued actually look like
a real person's apartment that someone lives
in the notches a bunch of beer rooms with
like by recording space so be sure to subscribe
to get everything if you guys and see my warcraft
video the full trailer for that is coming
on Friday I'm doing a special giveaway for
this watch my watercraft teaser video if you
don't know what's going on with that white
as way for everything to post you can click
here for that that were cracked teaser video
if you haven't seen it yet and you can click
here for last night's episode of the flash
probably one of the best episode of season
Thank You so much for watching, everybody
let's High Five and I'll see you tonight!